шість років тому українська нація взяла в
руки зброю
щоб захистити свою богом цю землю
нам сказали ви кропу та ми сказали
добре нам сказали б бендера ти ми
сказали добре нам сказали ви карателем
y добре
каратель зараз нам кажуть ці до суду та
доводячи свою не вином і ми світові добре
окей ми згодні ми доведемо лише час
йде і обов'язково буде суд у якому
свою невинність бутика 2 навіть не
це будьте печерський сорт це буде
народний трибунал
ось там ось істиною пам'яті або в залі
пам'яті творці міністерство оборони нехай
вибирають де їм буде зручніше там буде
дванадцять присяжних
6 учасників виніс Росії
з усіх волонтерів і доводитимуть
свою невинність
слова на півтора роки тому нам говорили
вибери бійтеся ви поїдете з України все
капець вам би в свою чергу говорили
цей клоун для якого українця не що
інше як актриса німецьких фільмів для
якого немає вдома, а термос заллє все до
чого дотягнеться нам сміялися в обличчя
раділи минуло півтора роки
так хто мав рацію все до чого
дісталися
а мене бога віра я як російськомовний
бендерівець як для назвали чотирнадцятим
року
хочу сказати цим клоунам які сидять
на банківській
чіпаєте мову не встигнете добігти до
вокзалу простим я вже не говорю петлі
тут стоять тисячі українців, щоб там
за верховною радою будь паяти десятки і
сотні тисяч українців не спробуйте
прийняти цю просту ознакою спробуйте
стати маріонетками кремля перед тим 60
узагальнених депутатів які побігли до
операційну сон спробуйте спробуйте
стати віч-на-віч
нацією
[оплески]
я говорив кажу і говоритиму головне
наша зброя це бідність чотирнадцятою
році ми забули всі чвари то за кого
голосував взяли в руки зброю і пішли
воювати в батальйонах доходило до того
що хлопці сиділи один навпроти одного я
звичайно бачив під широкіно
коли стежив бояться злого, а навпаки
сидів полковник національної гвардії вони
сиділи пили пісні кави та згадували
майдан а то візарді був на майдані а
полковник назвати хвилини я був по інші
сторони барикад а зараз ми тут стоїмо
разом усі разом захищаємо свою україну
п'ять років вірніше вже 6 нам сюди
скидали зерна розбрату не зерна
величезні камені аю-даг поменше буде
нам розповідали ви сауні воюють воюють
обробляти ж момент розповідає
обробляють воюють васу потім
розповідає про національну гвардію вони
зупинилися на цю ходу і тепер ми
пожинаємо свої плоди
коли мені запитують питала що робити
не хочу відповідати в риму йа раббі
deviation забувати раз ти не назавжди
леді можеш назавжди забути хоча б на
час озирнись навколо
перевір бронежилет та каску і як
правильно говорили поки хлопці там
тримають червону лінію взводних опорних
пунктів щосекунди ризикують своєю
життям заради величі українців
ми тут повинні зберегти
тил тому що путін не потрібен порошок
шляху але не потрібен крим або донбас путіну
потрібна вся україна
cougar вони справжні на колега у патіо
дорогий
який кидатимуть якісь знижки на
газ не розповідатиму там про велич
загальної історії аваддон народі в труні я
бачив такий один народ ми сюди нікого не
звали прийшли на нашу землю зі зброєю
тут пади залишитеся на моїй футболці
написано крим україна
я тут хочу звернутися до кримчан ми
обов'язково повернемося обов'язково
український прапор буде рейду даю давим
обов'язково український план буде майоріти
над севастополем обов'язково українська
прапор
я це гарантую бог свідок свята
софія свідок український прапор буде
майоріти над донбасом
і луганському україна буде великою
державою
[оплески]
зараз подумайте уважно в Україні
зараз в Україні готується ґрунт для
російського rivage та те що ми зараз ми
бачимо це ще не любиш ця підготовка
поки зелена влада ось ці перелякані
скривджені політики поки вони розмивають
кордону кордону армії
я вже не армія мова вже німого віра вже
не віра готується ґрунт для приходу сюди
намісника кремля президент
прем'єр-міністр голова парламенту так
кремлі планують подальше наше життя
ось вийде у них або не отримаю за
вийде під люк приз 1 США дуайтом по
україні
[оплески]